THE PRESIDENT.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US WHAT
SHE IS HEARING.
>> AT A TELEVISED CABINET
MEETING, EMBATTLED VETERANS
AFFAIRS SECRETARY DAVID SHULKIN
SWITCHED SEATS TO SIT NEXT TO
THE PRESIDENT.
CALLS FOR HIS REMOVAL HAVE HAD A
FEVERED PITCH.
A SHIFT IN TONE.
>> SECRETARY SHULKIN HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB.
>> AND INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
REVEALED DAVID SHULKIN ACCEPTED
WIMBLEDON TICKETS.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING WHETHER HIS
SECURITY DETAIL WAS MADE TO RUN
PERSONAL ERRANDS AND DELIVER
FURNITURE FROM HOME DEPOT TO
SHULKIN'S HOME.
THE PRESIDENT IS CONSIDERING
REPLACING SHULKIN WITH
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY SECRETARY
RICK PERRY.
TODAY PERRY TOLD REPORTERS HE'S
NOT INTERESTED.
>> I THINK RICK PERRY WOULD
REALLY SHAKE THE PLACE UP.
>> ADDING TO SHULKIN'S HEADACHES
IS A GENERATIONAL DIVIDE AMONG
VETERANS GROUPS.
THOSE SERIOUSLY INJURED FROM THE
IRAQ AND AFGHAN WARS WANT THE VA
TO MOVE FASTER TOWARDS GIVING
THE VETS THE CHOICE OF SEEING
PRIVATE DOCTORS.
>> THIS IS A GENERATIONAL ISSUE.
YOUNG VETERANS DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE NEED TO DRIVE 30 MILES TO
GET A PERCEPTION FIELD WHEN WE
HAVE A PERFECTLY SUITABLE
PHARMACY TWO BLOCKS AWAY.
>> TRADITIONAL VETERANS GROUPS
HAVE COME TO SHULKIN'S DEFENSE
AND WORRY THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
SUPPORTERS WANT TO PRIVATIZE THE
VA.
>> SECRETARY SHULKIN HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB.
LEGISLATION PASSED AND PROGRAMS
CREATED.
I WOULD BE SAD TO SEE HIM GO.
>> SECRETARY SHULKIN IS AN OBAMA
HOLDOVER.
HE RECEIVED 100 VOTES DURING HIS
SENATE CONFIRMATION HEARING AND
WAS ONCE A FAVORITE OF THE
PRESIDENT.